I'm so very glad that I was able to get
this poster for The Hangover Part 3 for
my hangover part 3 review I'm going to
put this in my background now I think I
will put it right here for this review
because I would like to have this poster
here in my background right next to the
Avengers and drive so I'll just I'll put
it right there for the review The
Hangover Part 3 is directed by Todd
Phillips and stars Bradley Cooper Zach
Galifianakis Ed Helms ken Jeong hazard
Graham and John Goodman this is the
third film in a very unexpected trilogy
you wouldn't really expect it a film
like the hangover which spawned two
sequels and make a trilogy out of it but
it did the first hangover was an
original movie that had an interesting
premise and likable characters and some
interesting comedy even though a lot of
people don't really find it that funny
which I can understand it had a
different vibe to it which was kind of
cool Hangover Part 2 is really just a
big copy off the first one where it felt
like they were just trying to do
everything again just in a different
location and it just didn't work
so when Hangover Part 3 they're changing
up the plot a little bit but a lot of
the same essential things stick with it
in this film John Goodman kidnaps the
wolf pack and forces them to find Ken
Jong's character chow because he stole a
ton of gold from John Goodman so the
wolf pack sets out on a mission to find
Chow and bring him back to John Goodman
every once in a while a movie will come
along that is just so blessed that it's
really hard for me to muster up any type
of enthusiasm to talk about it Hangover
Part 3 is such a mediocre movie there's
just nothing really here and it seems
like everyone involved that is just
straining to try to find something funny
to do or something big and
larger-than-life and huge and out of
this world it just seems like most
people involved with this production
including the actors are just like
grasping at straws they're trying to
find some little nugget of comedy to be
able to extract out of this franchise to
be able to get as much money as they can
out of it it's just such a blab movie
there's just really nothing about this
movie that is really remarkable and I
can't really pinpoint anything about it
that is just so like awful
you know like I can't really rant about
this movie it's just so
middle-of-the-road mediocre I like most
all the actors in this movie especially
Bradley Cooper who honestly kind of
feels like he's beyond this at this
point because he's good as his character
he just doesn't want to be there it just
it really seems that way as you watch
this movie after seeing silver linings
playbook and the place beyond the pines
and being blown away by his performances
he was Oscar nominated for silver
linings playbook and when you watch this
movie it just really feels like most of
the people are just kind of getting what
they can out of it and it just doesn't
really feel like there's anything left
in the franchise because the first movie
did it already it's one of those movies
where it's like it doesn't really need a
sequel it's just as likeable characters
but it did everything in the first movie
it's a hangover and they had a big fun
hangover okay well you don't have to
send them on some thriller basically
because this movie really is essentially
a thriller more than it is a comedy and
that's one of the weird things about
this movie is it tries to balance like
shootouts and car chases and kidnappings
gliding off of a building and scaling a
building where you might fall and die
and then it sidetracked that with like
really sophomoric humor mostly from Zach
Galifianakis and an extremely annoying
to me
can John Ken Jong has this thing that
he's kind of done for himself this
little thing he's edged out for himself
in Hollywood where he plays these really
loudmouth fast-talking idiots and he's
good at it but it's one of those things
where if you like the character of Chow
you'll probably like this movie a lot
more than I did because I don't really
like that character every other scene of
this movie he's in your face and he has
these really long monologues and a
karaoke song and stuff and it just
really really grates on the nurse my
nerves anyway if you like that character
it's gonna be fun for you to see him
because in this movie a lot like he's
just all over the place in this movie
but it really became annoying for me and
I couldn't really stand his character
anymore
I just got to be honest I didn't really
find this movie that funny and when a
comedy isn't funny
you know that that's kind of it The
Hangover Part 3 is not an awful movie
it's not terribly directed it's not
horribly acted or anything it just it
feels like everyone involved with this
production was just kind of going
through the numbers making the third
movie okay let's do
there just wasn't really anything
special or remarkable about this movie
at all and it wasn't very funny and the
times where it was trying to be really
super funny it just kind of came off
annoying I'm gonna give the Hangover
Part 3 a c-minus if you like the first
one in the second one you probably find
some enjoyment watching this one as
always guys thanks for watching and if
you liked this review you can click
right here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]